[Musique]
on l'attend
ce btr 80 de 1986 rejoint la ligne de
front
deux soldats surveillent les tranchées
craignant la proche d'éclaireurs russe
zoom lehmann
son nom de guerre est caporal lui et ses
équipes maintiennent leur défense dans
cette tranche est au coeur du dombass
malgré un déséquilibre des forces qui se
font face
[Musique]
c'est l'envié les troupes russes
auraient 20 à 30 fois plus d'armements
que
le phosphore est interdite les bombes à
sous munitions sont interdites
les mines antipersonnel aussi mais il
utilise tout ça dans cette guerre ils
les utilisent car il n'appelle pas ça
une guerre mais une opération spéciale
ils pensent qu'il ne brise pas les
conventions internationales
certains soldats sont à bout mais
parviennent à se détendre avec les
moyens du bord
cela fait trois mois que talisman est
ici
on est trop fatigué on n'en peut plus
on n'a pas de temps de repos
vous êtes allés dans les tranchées
eh bien ça fait depuis le premier jour
on est ici on les creusent des tranchées
il est aussi assistant cuisinier
il ya deux jours un chevalier
au menu ce soir le traditionnel boersch
ukrainien un moment de retrouvailles
entre camarades de guerre parmi eux ce
soldat qui a participé à des combats
intenses acier l'hérault de niet pendant
34 jours
j'espère que nous serons assez nombreux
ici mais je ne pense pas que le problème
soit au niveau des hommes on espère
juste que l'artillerie sera suffisante
dans mon champ car face à l'artillerie
tu ne peux pratiquement rien faire et
ils en ont beaucoup ont niché aux
chevrons
après le dîner un dernier moment de
tranquillité
mais la menace des drones n'est jamais
loin
mon premier objectif
les soldats font leurs rotations de nuit
prêt à faire face à l'ennemi
non on est chez nous
on sait parfaitement ce à quoi on fait
place un ennemi qui a énormément de
force mais ce n'est pas la première fois
nous sommes persuadés que nous avons
assez de ressources pour défendre ses
positions
la pire chose qui puisse arriver est
déjà en cours la guerre elle-même
au loin une bombe au phosphore explose
près d'oslo vian sq pour notre sécurité
les soldats nous ont même passé la nuit
dans un abri
la nuit la tension est constante
à l'aube aucun incident majeur sur la
ligne de front mais caporal prévient
la nuit et paisible la journée est
agitée c'est souvent comme ça
pour ce bataillon c'est une nouvelle
journée qui commence pour la défense de
ce l'audience qu lourdement frappé par
l'armée russe